Aristotle is when my heroes you know if
you say so who's a lifetime companion
for you sure it's my husband and my son
and daughter but it's also Aristotle
he's with me all the time and we have
kind of imbibed his lessons as you say
but we've also um he sort of it teaches
us that well one thing he teaches us is
in contrast to the Stoics I've also
written the last book was called the
stoic warriors about the stoic ethos of
the military and they say no place
through anger no place for grief no
place for the kinds of feelings that
make you um that make you vulnerable
detach detach detach so that you can
become strong and self-sufficient and so
you know what's in your power and of
those things that are not in your power
let them go leave them alone and that's
great news for a soldier because there's
so much it's not in your power when you
come at home when are you going to
redeploy will your wife still love you
will your boyfriend be there when you
come home all of those are so risky so
being in charge is an amazing things
suck it up suck it up suck it up was the
mantra of the naval academy when i was
there and always is but Aristotle is the
counter voice and he'll say it's
important to grieve because you are by
nature is social creature and you're
attached to other people and you are you
know virtue is in your capacity or in
your matter of your effort and a matter
of your resolve but a lot of whether
you're going to do well in this world
has to do with luck and has to do with
people that are outside you so Ariel
reminds us of that he reminds us also
that anger is a good thing because if
you the right kind of anger if you never
felt righteous indignation you would
never record the injuries and
indignities that people suffer you would
be you would be and you would be
indifferent to them so you'd have to you
should feel some anger the right anger
the right time toward the right people
similarly don't feel anger so much it
makes you survive but you are a slave to
your own anger but in a great weight so
he's very sensitive to the role of
emotions in the good life
and certainly I think and have been
arguing you know the past 10-15 years
through my work but the role of emotions
in a soldier's life can't be emphasized
enough they need to grieve they need to
recognize that they may feel betrayal
and that they have to reconnect with
their families when they come home they
one of my soldiers said no one ever told
me how hard the war after the war would
be meaning the the inner battles he has
to face so accepting and owning and
working through the positive and
negative emotions of war I think is
really an aristotelian kind of lesson
and you know I I'm very sympathetic to
the Stoics and the stoic warriors I felt
myself talking to them the whole time
and I had interviewed Admiral Stockdale
who was a senior poww along with McCain
John McCain and the Hanoi Hilton in
Vietnam North Vietnam and he had
memorized Epictetus a stoic philosopher
in order to get through he resonated
with it and it became his consolation in
seven and a half years of of prison two
and a half in solitary and and I think
that's an important voice the idea that
you will never be a slave to your
passions let's I potatoes or only those
things within your willpower can you
really can you really claim as your own
but it does have a downside of thinking
that you can really be unaffected you
can be invulnerable and I think that's a
real real hazard it's a moral hazard
real moral risk so Aristotle would would
correct us on that one